Alright, so you've made commits, you
understand that a commit ID is a big
deal and now we're going to talk about a
two-step commit: why you have to use
'git add' and 'git commit'. Now remember when we make a commit ID that is pretty
permanent, right, that's in history.
So, this section over here is our log of
commits. It's like a story of all the
changes you've made to put together your
code base. But first, we have to get there,
right? So, you're working locally you make
some changes. Say you make changes to an
index.html and to a CSS file but you
don't really want those to be stored
together - the changes that you made were not logically related in anyway - that's
ok. That's what 'get add' is for. Git lets
you choose exactly which files you want
to include in the next commit so let's
say we want to do the index first so
we'll 'git add index.html' and they'll move
that file and git's metadata to the
staging area. Git knows that when you run
'git commit' only to include the index
file not the CSS file. So, any files in
the working directory, if you want them
to be included in the commit you need to
use 'git add' first. Once they're in the
staging area, Git's going to include them
in the next commit once you run
'git commit' and then all of those files, that snapshot of the repository, including
your changes, are stored with that 40
character sha-1 hash in history.